ich bin nicht ab nee ich bin es ja und
ich nehme jetzt laufen ihr können in der
aufnahme mit dabei sein wenn ihr wollt
servus es zunächst bekommt zu einem
neuen video und ich habe mir heute war
ausgedachten und zwar an habe ich
gedacht ich mag ja so teamspeak
verarschen nicht ehrlich gesagt aber das
heutige video wird eine teams
spielaktion beinhalten das habe ich mich
spontan ausgedachten zeige ich jetzt mal
auf meinen tss capt tv und dann greife
ich mir einfach mal einen zuschauer der
gerade getrennt um raus und nehmen mit
ihm auf und kann die wissen noch nichts
davon dass jetzt kommen so ok
hier ist ein board hier ist ein bot ist
ein bordell da ist eine op en neits ich
kann in meiner eigenen günstigste nicht
hören ihre als gerade inzwischen
permissions wo ich kann über ihn zu
hören war ist das ist gut das ist gut so
leute ich habe jetzt zwar noch keine
rechte aber hier und müssen channel und
die jungs haben ihr passwort gesagt die
gar nicht auf einem eigenen ts keine
rechte was geht ab mit der welt aber
okay besonders rein und gucken wie die
reagieren die leute was geht
hallo begrüßt euch habt ihr bock auf der
rhone jump league ich bin nicht ab nee
ich bin es ja und ich nehme jetzt grade
auf ihr können die aufnahmen mit dabei
sein wollt was wir können versuchen
leute wissen sowie staaten mal in einer
runde rein
diese müssen eine finden die neat noch
nicht voll ist weil die jungs kein
premium hamm und mokka und / die täter
sind jetzt nicht gekickt wird nicht nur
einen versuch
wenn nur ein versuch 0 93 21
und selbst geschaffene okay ihr seid
eine runde drin sehr gut
so leute schreibt man die kommentare was
ihr von der aktion haltet soll man sowas
mal öfter machen oder ist so was absolut
nicht reden ok ja dann jungs wie seid
ihr so drauf und jump wie gut oder
schlecht ist der schlechteste
na ja das ist natürlich so optimal
gerade kindern gibt gas blaulicht
fahrzeug geparkt
nein ich bin schwer ich habe schon
schwert wie sieht's bei euch aus findet
die offenbar oder eher nicht so wenn ich
finde ich dir im gesicht oder eher auf
dem bauch
ich bin ein bisschen motiviert
naja leute manchmal auf twitter
vielleicht schon mitbekommen
ich bin irgendwie mega verliebt immer
ein auto gerade das klingt sehr
materialistisch und scheiße und objekte
viel vielleicht sogar aber irgendwie
macht mich das glücklich ich hatte jetzt
drei tage dann nicht mein auto und das
bei so richtig üblen tricks wetter und
gibt es draußen gehwege musste fahrrad
fahren jetzt habe ich mein auto wieder
ich bin richtig froh dass ich so weit
von mir okay wie alt seid ihr eigentlich
erzählte bei euch jetzt neun tagen ist
klar natürlich ich bin 19
ok
ja also mega viele neue fokussieren
diese zweite station da auch niklas du
bist sogar vor mir was geht ab wo geht's
weiter bin ich bin ja ja ja ja
checkpoint okay du bist runter gefallen
du bist immer noch vor mir sagt dieser
aber es gibt auch wichtiger dinge im
leben als alzheimer oder gar überhaupt
diese diskussion zum beispiel ob ich
diese runde jump league gewinner dass
dadurch wichtiger drei blöcke vorsprung
hast du noch kann jetzt kommen jetzt
bewegt ich mich einfach nicht über kann
ich kann ich ihre war okay jetzt nicht
mehr der fall nicht runterfallen neue
liest immer nur vor mir
das wird ein kopf an kopf rennen alter
ist alex ist dritter platz von hinten
gesagt ach meine klasse liefern zehn
gartenhaus schau dann immer gespannt wer
hat die vermisste zurückschießen also
wer bei
schon recht erste komplette recht damit
also kaum hier zeigt welche damit
deshalb nie so hart ist aber dass im
bundesliga spruch oder der kommt aus dem
fußball oder ist sonne
ich bin jetzt einfach mal drauf ich bin
jetzt einfach mal ganz dumm davon
ausgegangen dass die zuschauer von mir
sei das ist richtig
also ich und du nicht hast du ziehst
hier nur auf dem testserver getroffen
es gab zeiten da habe ich komme mal hart
gesucht es tatsächlich nein also das
nicht gerechnet
ausschied niklas niklas das wird eng
ich weiß also ich hatte gerade eben
spontan die idee ich kann es auch noch
mal so sagen einfach mal hier auf den ts
draufzugehen und ränder mit leuten
aufzunehmen
die abo grad zu senden die ersten die
die ich gesehen habe hat ihr
beziehungsweise eigentlich wollte ich
mit kreisel aufnehmen aber der fall soll
das video gerade dies wahrscheinlich tun
nicht ärgern ich hab nur einfach keine
rechte gehabt ich hab einfach mein
eigenes keine rechte die die mail sogar
weil die alten sind die ganzen resetten
dann muss ich den leuten machen noch mal
in den arsch treten dafür seit drei
tagen
der wurde schon mehrmals wird jetzt
nicht mehr weiß aber mehrmals ist ab 2
ist er mehrmals eines mannes ist bislang
spiel ja aber zweimal würde glaube ich
schon gerettet also leute den ts muss
man noch hinkriegen da rede ich mit den
abriss mit abblocken nicht dass du echte
bis heute gab das ist so wie fake sorry
du hast keine rechte mehr gemacht
ja ich ja ich meine ich bin noch echt
also werde jetzt auch nachher sehen ich
lade das video jetzt gleich hoch das
kommt heute noch meinem channel online
ihr könnt ihr nochmal kommentieren
niklas 40 7 oder vista auf youtube beim
niklas 40 73 euro gott die kürbisse und
du weißt du es alex auf youtube oder wie
maxi verraten wie der heißt oder nicht
und jetzt ein richtiger name da muss
natürlich sagen oh ja ja gar kein
problem nein
die kürbisse da bin ich auch letztens so
verzweifelt im stream
da kommt schon ein okay da muss man sich
halt hart konzentrieren könnte diese
kürbis sequenz da die diebe kürbis
sprünge werfen oder sind jack o lantern
bist du auch danach
ich denke ich bin noch bei den stein zu
denken
ich kann mir wenn ich ein bisschen
gebraucht und jetzt endlich über den
kursen absturz dies beginnt schon jetzt
leben
jana ist okay und naja zum sieg gereicht
hat auf fucking letzter sprung jetzt
aber ich mache jetzt mal einen
konzentriert durchlauf fuchs nicht so
aber lustig zu sehen dass der ts auch
von anderen leuten als zuschauern
genutzt wird entsetzt ich kenne ich
wahrscheinlich so vorher einer gesagt er
komme besonders cool war sonst immer
hauptanlass tsg essen dann hab ich halt
mal gesagt dass er das war eine gute
entscheidung war eine gute entscheidung
denn als ob du direkt geschafft ist
geschafft ich verzweifelt dazu
doom und dämlich alter okay das wird
nichts mehr heute in diesem leben nicht
leute jetzt gehen wir ernsthaft match
zehn sekunden denn sie wissen nicht
warum von counter verliere ich dass nach
so leute jetzt hallo hissen
wir nehmen wird auf ok hier oben ist
einer
aber müssen nachher sowieso mal reden
wegen ts resetten und so neu neulich bei
dem unter geilo timing
naja ok dann habe ich das muss ich meine
maus spielen kurz auch wenn die spinnen
muss auch im spiel beim nächsten 21
ich kann ihn nicht schlank nein da kommt
meine gucken da war glaube ich da war es
gibt ihnen jetzt wo es mal kekse essen
ich gebe euch einfach mal guten
ratschlag wenn ihrem leben irgendwann
probleme einfach ein keks essen hilft
immer weiter egal was absatz nach
abstauber ist raus ich hoffe nicht
schlank ja okay ist das verhältnis
seiner kenntnis nach einer
sprossenfenster warum machen
am 22 wir können es schaffen werde ich
meine eigene frau was geht ab so und
jetzt gehst du
oder du neues leck wie hat es leckt
alter schwede hatte der 19 aber etwas
anderes
nein und ich bin tot was leider wie
gesagt wenn ich die aktion gefallen hat
dann lasst gerne daumen nach oben da
schreibt meinen kommentar was ihr davon
haltet
und ja wir sind zunächst wieder rein
macht es gut und